[Music]
the Internet has been abuzz with rumors
and speculation the past week following
the reveal of the Titan Season Finale
trailer this trailer not only gave
viewers our first glimpse at Batman but
it also apparently showed that the Caped
Crusader had gone off the deep end and
murdered his rogues gallery there were
cries of outrage from some diehard DC
fans whilst others absolutely love the
new take but the episode synopsis
reveals that this may indeed be a bait
and switch the synopsis which has just
been released by DC states in the season
finale trigons powers send dick into a
dreamscape that begins with him living a
happy domestic life but soon takes him
into a dark journey back to Gotham it's
pretty clearly highlights that this
episode is therefore going to be a
hallucination and whilst we may get to
see an even darker dark night it doesn't
seem as if this will be permanent I
think this episode may take a similar
style to the batman the animated series
episode perchance to dream
in that episode Batman was captured by
the Mad Hatter and put in a machine that
made him believe he was living out his
perfect life eventually things went dark
though and Batman had to face himself in
order to escape obviously I can see many
fans getting annoyed by this new
synopsis while some will probably love
it so make sure you let me know below
which side of the fence you fall on and
why if you enjoyed this video then
please like it and check out my
breakdown of this week's other big DC
property Aquaman which will be linked at
the end this is the channel for people
who are super into superheroes so if
that's the kind of thing you like hit
subscribe thanks again for taking the
time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best and I'll see you next time take
care peace
[Music]